hi guys welcome to reality check I'm Seb
filling in for cam as following last
week's episode he's decided to go and
colonize Mars and until he returns to
our lovely home planet I the mighty set
board will be giving you your weekly
science dose open wide here comes the
space boat
[Music]
life is full of questions will the
amazing spider-man 2 video game be any
good who knows did I only bring this
spoon in here for that one gag yes I did
but back to spider-man one thing we can
be sure of is that it's going to involve
a whole load of web slinging
wisecracking and just general feats of
superhuman strength he does have the
proportional strength of a spider after
all
in fact loads of characters and games
display above human levels of strength
all the time not just superheroes but
rather than comparing loads of
individual game characters I thought it
would be better to look at the limits of
our own personal human strength and ask
do we all in fact have the ability to
exhibit superhuman strength in general
all our super-strong gaming characters
have to be just that super strong all
the time now you and I have a fairly
good idea of how strong we are lift a PC
oh that's a problem lift a car perhaps
not of course we could just hit the gym
but could we be stronger at a moment's
notice there are countless stories about
real people who in times of intense
stress or crisis are able to perform
apparently superhuman feats lifting far
beyond what they should be able to
perhaps in order to save a loved one a
stranger or a Scottish work colleague
but is it actually possible to lift
extra weights in a time of stress well
fortunately the science of how much we
can lift has been studied you see every
individual human being has a theoretical
maximum that they can possibly lift
their so-called absolute strength at
some point no matter what the strenuous
action you're trying to do if you were
to continually increase the weight you
would eventually get to a point where
your skeletal structure can no longer
handle it no matter how much you want to
lift it and how much mental strength you
have tissues would fail bones would
break and you would cause yourself
serious damage
on the other hand your maximal strength
is the limit you can achieve with
conscious efforts under normal
conditions or to gamers the limit before
your Skyrim character is over encumbered
and can't run now for the average person
maximal strength is about two thirds of
absolute strength so if I'm trying my
hardest I can probably lift around a
hundred and thirty kilograms but the
theoretical max that my pesky human
frame can handle could be as much as a
hundred and ninety-five kilos that extra
33% might not sound like much but it
could make all the difference between
lifting or dropping that
life-threatening object okay but how do
we access that extra third of strength
and why does being put in a stressful
situation help us achieve it well you
may have heard of the fight-or-flight
response during a stressful situation
the body enters that state also known as
the acute stress response the key here
is the activation of what's called the
sympathetic nervous system so wait
what's that
well the autonomic nervous system which
basically controls all involuntary body
function the things you don't have to
think about like digestion and heartbeat
is split up into two parts the
sympathetic and parasympathetic the
latter controls so-called vegetative
functions whereas the sympathetic is all
about function under stress and staying
alive so when a potentially dangerous or
stressful situation hits us this side
takes over releasing adrenaline or
epinephrine which has a variety of
effects on our bodies Airways become
relaxed for better oxygen absorption
heart rate is accelerated tunnel vision
occurs for more precise focus digestion
slows down muscles become primed for
action and the painkiller dopamine is
released by the brain a whole host of
things which get your body primed and
ready to do whatever it needs to stay
alive and it's in this state that we're
most likely to be able to exhibit extra
strength now it may not be giving us car
flipping levels of ultra muscle but it
is interesting to think that in our own
way we can all become a former
superhero if only 33% stronger than we
were before now how can we trick our
minds into achieving that state well
there is always the possibility of
highly dangerous and super illegal drugs
how about phenols cyclohexyl piperidine
or PCP
now this chemical doesn't actually make
you any stronger but it does have the
ability to make you think you are it
does this by distorting your perception
of sight and sound and producing
feelings of detachment from the
environment and self as well as a
numbing of the extremities this combines
to give the user the illusion of power
as a result those who take the drug
invariably cause themselves serious
injury while trying to do stupid things
so for strength it's really not worth
the risk for now we're just going to
have to accept the fact that we can't
swing a 200-pound Buster Sword casually
over our heads and we can't whole motor
vehicles at our real-life enemies
certainly not at least without
mechanical assistance but what do you
make of this idea of super-strength and
have you ever been in an incredibly
stressful situation that's allowed you
to become stronger than you thought
possible
do let me know in the comments
underneath last week on reality check
cam was discussing the possibility of
humans colonizing Mars within our
lifetime however it looked like the Mars
one project was the only possibility and
even then it would be a one-way trip
youtuber Thunder monkey chops great name
came back with this dose of info there
is another company SpaceX I've heard
that in the future they'll be able to
bring people to Mars for five hundred
thousand dollars sort of like a tourist
attraction so we're not too far off from
that sort of thing you're absolutely
right SpaceX is pushing to reach Mars
including getting our first probe to
land take samples and finally return
back to earth you can even buy one of
their rockets for as little as 57
million dollars it's actually fifty six
point five million but I will be needing
my 500 grand Commission to get me to
Mars thanks for watching this episode of
reality check don't worry cam we'll be
back next week to fill the
scientifically accurate
boots I was thinking they felt a little
tight in the meantime I will be seeing
you around
oh that's a problem Oh sir
I really tended the floor yeah it's
really bad that's gonna stain it lat it
couldn't have landed more on the corner
if I tried